okay welcome back from lunch so for the
second part of the differential privacy
and statistics mini course so Galton
hema who's a fellow here plus we'll talk
about theoretical computer science
perspective on the material as I talked
about thinking this is here all semester
and hopefully set up a discussion that's
all thank you John thank you John and
Adam for inviting me and also for their
valuable feedback on this talk yeah so
today I'm going to give you maybe this
should not be a TCS perspective that's
rather very broad at least it's my
perspective as a theoretical computer
scientist and this talk will be
mentioning things that sort of from a
TCS or a statistics perspective let me
note that there's other players in this
game who implicitly like work maybe in
one or the other including information
theorist and machine learning but I'm
just to keep it simple I'm going to
refer to statisticians and theorists
maybe has very broad generalizations
okay the structure of this talk will be
roughly as follows in the first set in
the first part I'll describe er setting
the type of goals we focus on maybe a
little bit a little bit more
philosophical in some sense like why do
we care about these problems the second
and third part all talk I'll go more in
depth on specific applications including
hypothesis testing and distribution
estimation and then in the last part
I'll just mention a few other problems
which have been studied as well and if
anytime anything is unclear of course
feel free to ask this can be as
interactive as you want okay so let's
start off by just seeing the difference
between algorithms versus statistics in
the very classical algorithm setting
what we would imagine is we have some
sort of data set x1 through xn this is
fed into some algorithm m and we achieve
some sort of utility based on how
accurate our answer is Y with respect to
the original data set so this is very
bit abstract but this is kind of like a
very static there's some given data set
and you want to infer something about it
however I usually picked your statistics
as being a little bit different so we
have the same sort of you know data we
run an algorithm on the data set of
course but the target isn't really a
utility with respect to the data set the
target is Rayleigh
utility with respect to some unknown
sampling distribution so now the picture
is like as follows you have a
distribution P which is unknown that
distribution generates some data set x1
through xn then you feed that data set
it into an algorithm which will give you
some output Y and the idea is you get a
utility derived on some it'll it's some
function of the original distribution
and the output essentially you want to
approximate the original distribution
not the actual data set so this is a
general setting we're going to focus on
and we have two main desiderata the
first is errata is kind of the non
private guarantee we want first of all
of course in any setting that our
algorithm is accurate this in this case
we're going to have it be a stochastic
guarantee stochastic in the following
sense
we want our algorithm to be accurate
with high probability over the data
generating process in the sense that you
know if you're sampling from
distributions there's always some
randomness and wacky things could happen
but assuming not too wacky things happen
we want our algorithm to accurate and in
particular this may require certain
assumptions about our generating
distribution to hold for example in
might we might require to be Gaussian or
from multinomial or something like that
we'll revisit this a few times during
the talk and so become more clear
perhaps what I mean by assumptions but
the other requirement is privacy which
we want always so that is for any sort
of realization of the data set we really
want to make sure the algorithm is
private no matter what sort of low
probability events happen yes so already
decided you mean that the
you mean that the algorithm is
preserving what do you mean inclusive
and I don't want to it it's it's pretty
much in the same setting like if you
just sort of ignore the distribution P
we're going to say that essentially if X
is our data set then the output of M X
is private in the usual sense we've been
referring to so far I'll define it in a
few slides but yeah essentially just
think about it in the same way we've
used it in all the other talks so far
but it's especially key that for any
possible input that is private and we'll
do a bit of philosophy about this in a
few slides and in this talk I'll pretty
much always be using a epsilon
differential privacy except noted
otherwise but really I don't want to get
too much into the weeds about epsilon
vs. approximate differential privacy
privacy any any questions about the
broad yeah Prasad yeah and we'll revisit
that in a few slides but just to sort of
show you I guess these two desiderata
the type of inputs and what what might
happen I imagine for example we want to
run a private algorithm on some data
which is Gaussian in the sense that we
sort of assumed the underlying
distribution is Gaussian so I generate
some sample from a Gaussian distribution
in this case we want our algorithm to be
private and we also want it to be
accurate but let's suppose you know we
get our data set but it isn't actually
Gaussian looking it looks something more
like this so you know this doesn't
obviously looked like a Gaussian to
anyone but even in this case we still
want to be private though we may not
have the utility guarantee for our
algorithm so hopefully that's clear
let's revisit this a question that
Prashant asked why worst case privacy
well there's a few different reasons why
you might want a worst case privacy
really over any data set and one reason
is that you could violate privacy of
outliers in the sense that you know if
you have a if you have one data point
which lies far outside what you'd expect
then maybe it might not you still want
to maintain their privacy like let me
give you an example to make a bit more
concrete perhaps
and you had a salary data set that is
you know all the employees who work at a
company you get their salaries and you
want to somehow privately output some
statistic of this data set for example
maybe the median salary one possible way
of doing this is appropriately noising
the data set and then releasing that
noise data set so let's take a look here
I generated a bunch of numbers which are
sort of centered at $65,000 which is
perhaps the salary and you can see that
I it and now this noise data set is
somehow it looks kind of believe me when
I say it's private in this case at least
and it looks like sort of sure this is
noise but let me say what if there's an
outlier what if your data set you know
has say a manager or some higher-up who
makes a lot more money than everyone
else then if you do the same type of
noising then you get this individual out
here so you can see like he makes still
about three hundred thousand dollars
what this is what this example is meant
to convey is that while in the left
setting while sort of we know the data
is well concentrated and noising it
would preserve privacy here in this case
where we might have an outlier we did
not preserve the privacy of this
individual and so there's the type of
thing we generally want to avoid I mean
maybe you can make some argument about
how capitalism is evil and we should
identify this individual but that's
perhaps the discussion for this evening
so yeah I hopefully this convinced you
that you know an individual's privacy
could be violated as a result of being
an outlier and another reason perhaps is
that statistics can be retracted but
private information can't really be
retracted this is something that Kobe
mentioned yesterday like a post privacy
world in the sense that for example it's
not uncommon for okay it's it's I think
it's somewhat uncommon but it's not
unheard of for there to be publication
saying that like this study has been
falsified of whether they'd be able to
be reproduced whereas once you tell
someone something that's private there's
no real going back from that so perhaps
we want to be a bit more conservative
yes
go back to the previous slide yeah so
yes that um
is the ugliest privacy violation of the
utility being violated because
presumably that orange thing is the
noisy data that you release yes I don't
see any orange around that person and so
it sounds like you just kind of did not
have that person at all which will
affect your utility but not your privacy
right so I actually didn't like what I
see what we can do here like the ideas
we want to compute the median in some
way and one possible way is sort of
knowing the data set and then releasing
it and then on this release two data set
to compute the median I claim that the
median should be roughly the same for
both these data sets after noising but
if we sort of release the data set early
then it would before computing the
median then it would still violate this
individual's privacy that make sense
I'm saying that if you wanted to say
privately release the data set forget
about any particular statistics then the
one on the left would seem to maintain
privacy but the one on the right
identify that someone has a very high
salary in this yeah there is noise but
it's above a much smaller scale because
uh sorry it's the same scale but you
know it's it doesn't move him or her
that much right no no believe me there
is noise added but it's up a fairly
small scale which doesn't show up well
here cool thank you okay and what sort
of privacy guarantee do we want well
differential privacy so we want
differential privacy let me just state
in one sentence in cases the first time
you're seeing it again essentially on
data sets which differ and only one
entry then you want the probability
distribution of your algorithm to be
very similar so there's a bit of a
mouthful and we won't actually need it
for today too much the thing that I may
refer to I will refer to back and forth
a few times is the idea that less
sensitive statistics will be cheaper to
privatize maybe you've heard before but
let's try to make this a little bit more
precise we're going to be trying in
general to compute some function f and
the sensitivity of f can be seen as the
maximum difference on neighboring data
sets in other words if you take X and
then you change one data point and ax
either add it or remove it or replace it
in some way and you take the difference
between the function value on those two
data sets
then take some norm of it I won't go
into which one this will be the
sensitivity the most we can change might
be familiar to a lot of you so I'm just
going to in Kate that to make sense just
let's say sensitivity and privacy are
somehow related here and the next thing
I want to talk about is what we mean by
utility this will generally be a problem
specific thing whether we're doing
hypothesis testing or distribution
estimation but the general statement
which we're going to be trying to
understand is how much data is needed to
approximately and for a property if the
underlying distribution P with high
probability the very broad question I'll
like be more precise in a bit and if you
ask where this question comes from
perhaps statisticians would point to
this person Karl Pearson Karl Pearson
was alive at about like the year 1900
and he was a very respected and
impressive statistician he's famous for
a number of things including say the
methods of moments the chi-square test
and unfortunately also racial eugenics
that's a bit of a footnote but let's say
within within theoretical computer
science at least the person who we
consider what who I often consider to be
at least the father in more ways than
one yo C is less valiant who introduced
probably approximately correct learning
in 1984 and at a general level
packed learning is concerned with
statements of the falling form now this
is rather mathematical so let me try to
actually walk you through what this type
of thing means so the first segment of
this with n samples we're going to try
to understand how much data is needed
and I did n sub F gamma and alpha which
means that the data the amount of data
we need will be a function of what type
of problem we're trying to solve okay so
that's the data that we need now let's
take a look at this term inside the
probability we're going to say that M X
which is the output of the algorithm its
difference with respect to the function
on the unknown distribution is less than
gamma so it's saying that it's accurate
up to accuracy gamma and then when we
wrap in a probability we want this to be
correct with probability at least one
minus alpha so just to sort of repeat
this in sort of plain English we want
that our algorithm will give an output
which is gamma accurate at least one
minus alpha of the time or it's
approximately correct
probably
are there any questions about this type
of question about this okay so a running
three team through this talk is
understanding the cost of privacy which
is asking essentially how much more data
is needed to guarantee privacy of course
pretty much all of the problems I'm
gonna mention are going to be things
that we understand very well non
privately but we want to understand
really this additional cost due to
privacy
so in particular I will often write
sample complexities as a sum of many
terms and often the first term will be
the non private cost that is the sort of
baseline as what we have to pay and the
question is how big is this additive
term and in what situations is the
private cost much much larger than the
non private cost so one one thing that's
sort of a terminology thing that
sometimes is a bit of a have a bit of
friction between statistics and computer
science is what it means to be
asymptotic so let me sort of define -
meaning that what it means to be
asymptotic and we'll see hopefully how
they sort of refer to different settings
one is asymptotic settings asymptotic
statistics this is a session mentioned
this during her talk in the morning but
these essentially give guarantees when
the sample size approaches infinity and
then yeah other data set grows
increasingly large approaching infinity
so the most most common example of this
that you might have heard of is the
central limit theorem which in a sort of
basic state is a asymptotic statement
here's another example which we'll see
in a few more slides we're going to say
like as the sample size approaches
infinity we'll say some district will
converge in distribution to say a
chi-squared distribution so the the sort
of main thing about this that I want to
get across is it doesn't quantify the
error for any finite n but it says it's
sort of in an asymptotic setting this
error goes to 0 on the other hand
asymptotics are also highly used by
computer scientists but perhaps in
slightly different meaning in the sense
I usually mean big o-notation I mean big
o-notation when I mean asymptotics which
hide constant factors in lower order
terms and it's an example we're gonna
see to achieve accuracy blah blah blah
we require an equals o of this many
samples now what that really means is
you can you can okay what it really
means something a bit technical but this
can often be read as the following that
we require and to be greater than C
times this many samples for some
constant C now this constancy is often
not specified but that's often just view
up to a function of being perhaps lazy
rather than it being sort of impossible
to calculate or also just to simplify
the results in the sense the statement
of the case where it's easy to calculate
but embarrassingly large yes yes that's
also that's often the case so often
computer scientists will state well
state results up to like these constant
factors and not show them and I think
one really good question is is
asymptotically optimal T good enough
it's interesting because I think
statisticians often fall on either side
of this in the sense that either earth
sorry let me just say computer
scientists often asymptotic optimality
is good enough you know give me a wrap
it in a Big O and I'm happy
whereas statisticians often like to
either have asymptotic results or if
they're doing mini max results as these
sort of finite sample guarantees are
called they really want the right
constants as I mentioned in her talk
this is often very important to get
practically useful confidence intervals
and things like that
so I think it's kind of interesting
culture thing
is it fair to say that it's like stuff
on the left that you don't know you say
on the right that you know we hide to
secretly know it I feel like that maybe
that's not really a fair comparison I
think I think that the stuff on the left
is being you ignore low-water terms but
you worry about leave constant
I guess I've I've seen some things of
the statement like that this converges
to the right answer like as n approaches
infinity but what this kind of hiding to
me in these settings has been like that
the sample complexity the exponential
and dimension which is something that I
would prefer to understand better right
right okay but yeah like say people
doing two-dimensional geometry like hi I
had the dependence on - yeah at least my
personal taste I like to understand and
you know if it's a parameter even if
it's exponential I'd like to know that
but it depends indeed on the community
cool and uh I think my my interpretation
of this actually is more than when you
say that this it's asymptotically
distributed like this what you're really
trying to do is you're trying to get
those constants but your approximate of
only asymptotic yeah right because if
you're a statistician you told me okay I
just care about some like l2 error or
something and I don't really care about
convergence in distribution right I mean
we can do all this sort of standard
Thanks
so thank you I think it is sort of there
that two sensors are slightly different
in the sense they're sort of two
fundamentally different roles I think
right i I would agree in general yeah
either generally they're both valuable
things to study I think yes
they're not even any one so we have a
you know often sort of asymptotics and
finite sample are like opposed but in
some sense on the right the way
asymptotics is used it is really a
finite sample guarantee it may not be
like the best possible finite sample
guarantee but it's a statement about
finite samples sure was not derived for
that purpose yet was derived because I
time to get a handle of those constants
but I can only approximate them
asymptotically right I mean it's a food
if you're talking about you know just
convergence you know accuracy of
something I mean you can do they go Big
O P all the stuff it's right
there's also kind of quiet city
difference years like on the right side
we lay on the end of the day we just
want to say these stairs it works well
on the left side is also lame-o in this
statistic will behave as this thing so
for whatever like if you want to use it
for other things you can also do it like
deterring fear if we will test that
quote we don't also give its
distribution in taking back most of the
time we don't actually know it so show
the test words but if you want to RT for
something more qualitative about me oh
and also this rigid according to that
particle distribution so I know this
thing I'm gonna tease it somewhere else
we don't know yeah I think as you can
see this is like an interesting
distinction between the two which we can
discuss more of the coffee break ok so I
think one last distinction or like maybe
terminology thing that I want to point
out is sample complexity versus rates
maybe you've heard both these terms and
they're actually equivalent to each
other in in the type of statement I'm
going to make here today in the
following sense I'm going to present you
a theorem and then like two ways of sort
of finishing the sentence so this is a
theorem I'm not gonna prove it for you
but essentially if you have data which
is generated from a Bernoulli
distribution with some unknown parameter
we can see that there exists a private
algorithm which with probability 99% if
you take sufficiently many samples and
equals of 1 over gamma squared plus 1
over epsilon times gamma samples then
we'll have the guarantee that the
accuracy is less than it's accurate up
to gamma but another equivalent way of
stating this is kind of the following
for each n we have that the accuracy is
less than is the the the error rather is
less than 1 over root n plus 1 over N
times Epsilon and you can kind of see
that these are two sides of the same
coin if you sort of sub if you invert
one thing it'll give you the other I
will stick to the first statement but
if you're more comfortable ii just know
a corresponding statement does exist
cool so are there any questions before I
go to the first vignettes about
hypothesis testing
cool so hypothesis testing hypothesis
testing at a high level asks given some
sort of data set X was it generated from
some distribution P which satisfies some
hypothesis this is kind of self
referential but essentially these are
asking yes or no questions about the
underlying distribution P which
generated the data and we're we're going
to be concerned with in particular
testing h0 which is often called the or
h not the null hypothesis in the sense
does this hold today we're going to be
concerned with the null hypothesis is
the unknown distribution P equal to some
known distribution Q which is the model
of interest so there's no goes this type
of problem goes by many names including
say goodness of fit testing or one
sample testing computer scientists
invented the name identity testing for
confusing reasons but it I think it goes
by many names let's say and in
particular today we're going to focus on
the specific problem where Q is equal to
the uniform distribution but pretty much
every anything I say is going to be more
general so we're gonna be considering
the uniform distribution over the
integers 1 through K so you can see this
instantiated for K equals 10 the uniform
distribution and this is what's known by
sometimes statisticians as multinomial
data or the multinomial setting yeah
this is actually confused me a lot when
I first heard the term 1 sample testing
means the sense that you get data from a
distribution P only as opposed to two
sample testing where you have data from
two different distributions and you want
to test of the same distribution versus
not so it's not like literally just get
one data point there's still an N but
this is sort of the problem and it's
clear
cool and so our goal in sort of a
classical hypothesis testing setup will
be the following if H 0 H naught holds
that is we're actually sampling from the
uniform distribution we want the
probability of rejecting to be less than
alpha that is we want the probability of
saying that H naught is false to be less
than alpha this parameter alpha as has
been referred to before is the
significance it's the also known as the
false positive rate and of the two
constraints I'm going to mention here is
generally the more important constraint
and the easier one to control for
reasons we'll get into in a few points
the other goal you have is that if H H
naught doesn't hold then we want the
probability of not rejecting that is
saying that the null hypothesis does
hold is less than beta so the parameter
1 minus beta is called the power of the
test that is alpha is the false positive
rate beta is the false negative rate and
we say a test is perhaps good if it has
high power that is a it's got a low
false negative rate yes very good
question what if P is very close to I
promise he's not a plant and often it's
what's considered is an alternative
hypothesis H 1 H and so yeah often we
consider an alternative hypothesis H 1
which may be say parameterize in some
way of being far but in the asymptotic
setting which is what I'm going to
describe the next few slides let's just
say it's kind of for any distribution
which is not H naught in some sense and
one thing that I'll state is that you
can often control alpha but sometimes
have to measure beta in the following
sense when H naught holds then the
statistics distribution will be
predictable but may require asymptotic
approximations this sounds kind of big
but let's let's go
a bit more in-depth on to what I mean by
that so let's start with hypothesis
testing in the non private setting that
is looking at pearson's chi-squared test
and this is the statistic which is the
following there's a lot of parameters
but let me like tell you what all these
things are we'll walk through this
slowly and then we'll try to understand
it so you can see here what am I going
to say Q is going to be again the
uniform distribution over the numbers 1
through K because that's our model of
interest we want to test if it's equal
to that so in other words the Q eyes
will be the probabilities of each eye
which will be 1 over K because it's
uniform ni is going to be the number of
occurrences of domain element I and then
we have n being the number of samples so
this simplifies to this or this
expression sorry yeah this is the
statistic we're gonna be concerned with
and this is just very mathematical so
let me try to interpret this for you as
one way of looking at it and I will is
the true number of times we observed
domain element I where as n times Qi is
the number of times we'd expect to
observe element I so we're kind of
taking the difference between the
observed and the expected and then
squaring it and rescaling it for reasons
we'll get into this will be a natural
thing to do but perhaps is not the most
intuitive are there any question about
the statistic before I sort of talk
about properties of it
I'll give you an awkwardly long time to
parse this
well that was awkward enough so one
theorem is that this is this goes back
to I was saying that in the null
hypothesis case it's easy to understand
the distribution in some sense because
okay here's the theorem that you can
prove if the null hypothesis holds that
is like it's actually the uniform
distribution as we take at the number of
samples tends to infinity then we'll
have that this statistic will converge
in distribution to the chi-squared
distribution with K minus 1 degrees of
freedom where this isn't proud is the
sum of squared gaussians if you're
familiar with it great if not don't
worry too much about it it's just a
probability distribution we know and can
understand and the intuition again the
well the intuition behind it is the
following take a look at the account
minus the expected count and this
rescaling if you sort of squint at it
this looks kind of like the central
limit theorem and this will converge in
distribution to gaussian with the
appropriate with zero mean and the
appropriate variance and one thing I
want to point out is if this converges
to a Gaussian essentially the statistic
is the sum of squares of this thus
leading to the chi-squared distribution
there's a bit hand-wavy but that's
roughly where it comes from it's about
yeah that would I mean if you rescaled
by 1 minus Qi I guess that would just
make it and 0 1 yeah yeah so I kind of
moved it over to the right for reasons
and the idea is that so essentially what
this theorem says is again if you're
looking at samples truly from the
uniform distribution then we can predict
what the distribution will be of this Q
squared except in an asymptotic sense so
we're going to use quantiles of this
asymptotic distribution to determine the
test outcome in other words if we set
alpha to be point zero five we're going
to now compute the statistic and if it
falls in this tail it's too large then
perhaps we say okay I guess you'd really
want some mass here and some mask
but essentially if it falls and sort of
the red region you're going to say that
this couldn't be the uniform
distribution because that was very
unlikely but if it falls anywhere in
this white region then that's okay that
it could possibly be the uniform
distribution and essentially we say if
the statistic is too large yeah we
output that they're not equal
alternatively you might know the term
p-value this is essentially the same
thing as you know the Alpha here and one
thing I want to highlight here is that
this doesn't there's this two things I
want to note here one this doesn't
account for the asymptotic approximation
we just had an asymptotic result here
and there's no idea of how close it gets
for finite samples with the statement as
is and it also doesn't give guarantees
about the power which we'll revisit in a
bit yeah come on it's pretty painful
another two more to do but concrete set
up using the co2 you see there's some
constant version of it and get some bone
which she's gonna give us as a function
of alpha and all the time just some yeah
yeah I'm sure for this you can derive
some non asymptotic guarantees uh this
statistic to the best of my knowledge is
not optimal though yeah look and I found
one one finite sample size complexity
bound for this which is not the right
media
[Music]
so apparently they exist but they're
kind of like not the most common yeah
okay so this is the non private
statistic let's look at privatizing and
you know the this is a work by Marco
Gilardi Lim okay okay perhaps that's a
yeah it's not even clear what powers
should be in the sense that like we
don't have an alternative hypothesis so
it's perhaps not maybe maybe an
asymptotic sense the power will approach
one might be something you can drive I'm
not told one hundred percent sure I
think there are there are statements of
of the form you know if some measure of
distance a chi-squared distance between
P and Q is the police yeah yeah you know
you get some alternate sampling
distribution and so that implies some
power benefit agreed yeah I guess I this
slide does not contain any guaranteed
and in particular I didn't specify you
know an alternative hypothesis anyway so
it's imposed on all clear what type of
guarantees you would even give yes but
uh we'll revisit this I guess in a bit
here's like a very small deviation from
the null and then you know how about how
what is the probability that basically
every checked is it because you're right
you basically fixed alternative the
powers will just be what is product but
so how do you get some sort of measure
if you just let shrink a little bit
right
I guess one way of looking at yeah
perturbation that's the null hypothesis
in some way and maybe for that family of
perturbations you can reason about the
null about the power yes okay so here is
a non private test let's try to
privatize it and perhaps the first way
might do one might try to do this is by
noising it appropriately so I'm going to
be presenting some results here by gob
gob Ord limb Rogers and baton so the
first way you might think of noising it
is just to add Gaussian noise to each
count which is as we know private but
what can we say as they proven their
paper it's actually possible to prove
that this converges to the same
asymptotic distribution in fact so if we
try to we try if we try to follow the
same type of analysis this would suggest
we just use the same threshold but it
can be seen that the finite sample
significance guarantees are now bad
let me parse this table for you so
essentially the way this is done what we
try to do is set the significance to be
you know 5% chance of rejecting when we
actually have the null hypothesis and
you can see the bottom let's say the
bottom bar is what happens if we just
use the same threshold as before you can
see in the high sample case where you
have maybe a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand samples you get
something which is pretty close it has
like I guess an eleven percent chance of
rejecting which is a bit higher but in
you know the very finite sample Garant
setting then hyper finite high I think
that means something else yeah but in
the sort of say 10 samples you get you
know something that's not a meaningful
you essentially reject all of the time
so it's clear that somehow for finite
samples you need to adjust your
threshold yes this is a question
asymptotically my claim is that it'll be
the same distribution if n goes to
infinity but this it causes finite
sample guarantees you do noise
and in particular just knowing what you
wrote on the previous slide this could
also happen without the additional noise
for privacy but it happens that the non
private test performs well even with ten
samples directly even though in
principle the statement that converges
in distribution does not imply that
correct yeah so we just again to restate
what john said yes like it seems that
the asymptotic guarantees were okay in
the non private setting but when we go
to private setting then
something-something doesn't really work
as well as we'd hope and so there's two
possible ways which takes floor in this
paper which that figure was also from
one way is use Monte Carlo to determine
new thresholds that is say you know just
sample the statistic yourself like
essentially simulate samples from the
uniform distribution to see how it
behaves and you can find the right place
for the statistic threshold to get the
right significance but you can also
analytically understand the distribution
for finite n which takes a bit more work
you now get the significance being
accurate perhaps the power can be
improved there's other things you can do
like perhaps post-processing I just
wanted to give a shout out to this paper
which has a very surprisingly good
method I I enjoyed a lot by Dan Kiefer
and Ryan Rogers in which you try to post
project out the noise but everything
I've referred to so far has been sort of
non asymptotic and a question is can we
rigor rigorously reason about the
required size of the data set and this
reads to it leads to the definition of
minimax hypothesis testing or
distribution testing and here now we
finally at long last I define an
alternative hypothesis which will be all
distributions which are gamma far from
the null hypothesis Q and in particular
we're gonna do the l1 distance so let me
sort of parse what this picture looks
like for you so you can see we have the
central case here where you know P is
equal to Q this is a null hypothesis and
then out here we're going to have the
alternative hypothesis where the l1
distance between P and Q is at least
gamma the idea is that you know the
we're given the sort of guarantee the
promise that we follow
to one of these two cases and that you
know anywhere in the middle we don't
have to have the accuracy guarantees
sort of as I discussed at the beginning
of this talk is this make sense the idea
is that you have the alternative
hypothesis can be all distributions
which are far where l1 distance is
defined as the following if you're not
familiar another way of thinking about
it is the maximum discrepancy and
probability under any event I guess is a
privacy room so one way of saying it is
it's the two distributions are 0 gamma
differentially private with respect to
each other
I don't usually stayed in that way but
maybe for this room I will TV distance
and statistical distance l1 these are
all total variation yes these are all
synonyms roughly okay and one thing I
want to point out is that this is
parametrized by gamma this sort of in
contrast to the previous problems where
we sort of focused on you know
understanding alpha and beta the reason
for this is kind of because I claim that
once you get to the sort of alpha beta
equals 0.05 regime then you can boost it
to any arbitrarily high regime at a
logarithmic cost in the domains I say
but so this is a the main thing that we
focus on is sort of this
parameterization gamma how small is how
big is the distance between the null and
the alternative hypothesis in an
appropriate distance measure
so let me show you an optimal minimum
innomax optimal non-private test up to
constant factors then we'll see how we
might privatize that so one test which I
I'm for this was with a acharya and us
caucus we showed back a few years ago
that this is actually an optimal up to
in the asymptotic minimax optimal sense
an optimal test for testing identity and
one thing i want to point out is this is
very similar to pearson's chi-squared
test the one difference is that you do
this - and I essentially subtract out
the counts so this is this kind of weird
and why it turns out to be the right
sort of thing to do in the sense that
you can bound the variance and then
doing chebyshev's allows you to separate
the two count cases and get a sample
complexity bound but I think it's kind
of cool that looking at this from a
minim axe perspective gave us this tweak
which at least theoretically improves
the sample complexity in particular we
can get a sample complexity of the
following sort so let me interpret this
for you remember the domain size we're
looking at a distribution over the
numbers 1 through K we get a square we
get a square root of the domain size
this is perhaps surprising in the sense
that it is sub linear in the domain size
that is we don't even need to see all KL
moments even once before we can tell
that's uniform and yeah this was proven
that this in the first optimal test that
was also proven before the lower bound
is due to open in ski and the upper
bound is due to Greg and Paul Valley to
his sons of less valiant if you've been
paying attention yeah father in more
than one ways anyway so the sample
complexity of non the problem non
privately is root of this domain size
over gamma squared the natural question
here is how much does privacy cost and
so let's first try to get a baseline for
it I'm not sure I don't think I have
time to go over this in full detail in
this short but there is a framework
known as subsample in aggregate by
Nassim rush konnikova and smith which
essentially says
you know split it into different parts
and then combine them in some way
there's a very general framework which
is used for privatizing normal-ish
statistics also mentioned yesterday and
I think Elyas talk but essentially if
you implement it if you do this type of
subsample in aggregate you're gonna get
the following sort of baseline for
private hypothesis testing you get the
non private sample complexity with a
multiplicative one over epsilon which is
already pretty good to be honest it's a
nice baseline we didn't have to pay more
in the domain size we didn't have to pay
more in terms of gamma it's a nice place
to start but can we do better
sorry your previous slide yeah so you
see we're saying that the Pearson
chi-square is not yeah I think there is
a distributions you can construct where
under this problem it'll be linear
rather than square root this is like a
syntactic Rivlin to likelihood ratio I'd
have to think about it a bit more but I
thought we can construct an example like
oh this is sort of asymptotic as the
domain size grows it may be the case for
everything okay I squared is converging
to the likelihood ratio but the
convergence rate depends on the domain
size yeah yeah we generally picture the
domain size as growing to be very large
think of this is not a nonparametric
test is the right way to okay that's the
regime nerves you're in so but first so
for fixed K though this is yeah for a
fixed K then I mean everything is many
many tests are going to be 1 over gamma
squared for like a constant case okay so
it's actually the issue with the sorry
the question is whether we can uh you
know bound the sensitivities this
chi-squared test I'll point out that the
the statistic that we used in our in
that I mentioned a few slides ago I'm
gonna just a state that the sensitivity
is pretty much determined by this n
minus
this ni- nqi that is the true count
versus the expected count and this can
be very sensitive if a count is much
larger than its expectation the the idea
though is if something is much larger
than this expectation then it can't be
the right distribution so essentially
using this kind of idea we first
privately check if a count as much
larger than it's a expectation and if
it's not then we can sort of noisily
threshold the chi-squared statistic
that'll give you an algorithm with this
sample complexity the joint with the
brine sigh and my adviser back in the
day costa's yes yeah this does a little
sensitive to me Edward but I mean
consider the case where like all the
samples like the entire dataset falls in
I and then the other one has like very
small probabilities say like a qi is
zero so we could have sensitivity of k
and with a sensitivity of n rather just
where is the thing sensitive not this
absolute value everyone sort of had the
bigger this in yeah like the derivative
which is the difference is the like yeah
the sensitivity of this is determined by
this quantity anyway if you do the
calculations for this type of thing you
get something that's somewhat better
than before you still have this root k
over gamma squared but now the
additional cost is sort of less in some
it's sort of free in certain regimes
this is one sample complexity you can
actually do even better it turns out
like you might think that this is not a
good statistic because of the fact that
could vary so much because it has this
square it turns out there's a few better
as to statistics that are better for
this sort of thing for example one
statistic that works and is optimal for
this problem in a certain regime is
counting the number of things you don't
see that'll that'll give you something
that you can privatized which was done
by
about our poor dear Nicholas and
Rubenfeld and a bit surprising to me the
akka Nicholas it also showed that
empirical l1 distance which is a very
insensitive statistic can also be
privatized or sorry that this first of
all this algorithm works non privately
and it's very insensitive so you can
privatize it as well and if you do the
calculations you're gonna get something
that looks like this so I think this is
kind of interesting this is the optimal
sample complexity we have this first
term as before and then a slew of other
terms which I'm not going to read out
for you because they'll take like a long
time to get all those exponents yes
there are lower bounds in acharya some
zhang with zhang which shows that this
is tight so i think is kind of
interesting how you know this was the
non private complexity and once it
becomes a private we have three new
terms each of which is the dominating
term in some regime is there a principle
that won't you like how to come up with
these optimal tests like why do you
choose a specific form I mean it seems
like we're they're not even for non
private for the non private version of
this problem and it seems like the
ultimate test is not unique yeah yeah
this car consciousness
yes is there an intuition behind this
form of the test I guess one-one
intuition is that like okay well sort of
its unscented
well one observation is that for a
uniform distance TV is kind of you can
sort of estimated by looking the number
of collisions and chi-squared can be
seen as a way of rescaling it so that's
kind of uniform ish and then looking at
the l2 but this is probably I'm happy to
talk about this more offline are there
any question about hypothesis testing
before we the next main vignette I'll
try to get into in the last say 10
minutes or so will be distribution
estimation which is as you might expect
given an samples from a distribution
privately estimate the distribution this
lets the the main thing that I didn't
say here is what is this distance we
want to approximate the unknown
distribution in some sense but the
choice of distance is somehow
unspecified in this statement itself and
it's actually really it's really
important as we'll see in a number of
results here that I'll mention that the
cost of privacy can vary wildly
depending on the distance there's been a
good amount of work on understanding in
a non private setting but I'd say not
yet to end up the private setting it's a
good question though
ok let's see what we can do with
univariate learning that is just
one-dimensional problems first off since
we've been working with multinomial
let's see about privately estimating a
discrete distribution over 1 through K
and it's pretty much it's a folklore
result that just by noising the
empirical histogram you can get
essentially the domain size over alpha
square over gamma squared which is the
non-private complexity plus K over gamma
times epsilon so essentially no
additional cost in the domain size and
minimal cost in terms of privacy you can
see this calculation for example in a
work by Ilyas moritz and ludwig but the
point I'm trying to get across here is
that the cost of privacy is really
minimal in the sense it's nothing
changed too much I consider this to be
minimal increase however an interesting
result is showing that in Colma gora of
distance which is a picture that
look something like this the distance in
the CD f's this is a very easy distance
to estimate in a in non private settings
in the sense that you can just get one
over gamma squared which is independent
of the domain size but oddly I do this
result by diagonal Siemens stemmer you
get this additional additive you know to
to the OAuth log star K over gamma times
epsilon which is like a very very small
term if you're not familiar with log
star and this is actually tight tight
all right not tight in the sense that
like up to contract yeah the the lower
bound and upper bound or indeed
exponentially off but these are like
both incredibly tiny things so this is a
bit I don't know how to really quantify
this in the sense that this is actually
indeed a very expensive cost in the
sense that before there was no cost in
the domain size and now you have one
even if it's minuscule so this is like a
qualitative shift in the complexity
which i think is very interesting okay
so another youniverse
sure
so Cole MacGrath here distances it so I
mentioned the integers are ordered and I
really want the I'm sure start
translating this and writing down yes
okay yes all right yeah that's perhaps
the most uh like interesting part the
fact that even for continuous
distributions you can approximate in
Coleman Gaurav but you can't in the in
the private setting okay so also what
about gaussians I guess accession talks
a bit about this before but essentially
a result by car when LaVon shows that
the sample complexity is the is this
expression here and you can see that the
leading term is a you know still 1 over
gamma gamma squared which is the non
private complexity but now we have
interesting new terms here which sort of
depend on the scale and the position and
the range of the data in the sense we
really need bounds on the on the domains
on how big the mean and the variance are
now and this lets us estimate in l1
distance but the cost of privacy here is
really mild in terms of the scale
parameters but it's now again like
before something that wasn't there
before but now we've introduced it due
to privacy I'm going to mention multi
very learning product distributions in
the sense now suppose we have a
multivariate distribution we want to
privately estimate the mean of this
distribution and we're going to focus on
like binary product distributions here
the case with D equals three and in this
case I will actually demonstrate how the
choice of the distance in which you want
to estimate the mean can change the
sample complexity a lot so first off if
you just want to estimate an l2 distance
this turns out just you know the
univariate algorithm Laplace each thing
independently you get this result here
which essentially says that privacy
comes at minimal cost
and actually if you want to learn the
distribution in l1 distance then a
recent result with a Jerry Lee Vikrant
single and John almond shows that in
fact in this sort of stricter distance
measure then we can also estimate it at
sort of no additional cost
however if instead you were concerned
with say L infinity distance you want to
estimate the mean up to L infinity
distance now we can see something sort
of a new cost arising in the following
sense non privately the you'd have pay
the log of the dimension but with
privacy now you have the square root of
the dimension so in other words you had
to pay an exponential cost in the
dimension in order to get privacy so it
seems like there's a big difference here
let me just spend one minute saying why
we might consider an Alan Finney
distance in a phrasing that might make
sense more to you suppose we asked a
said you know we were asking a
population of people D different
questions and they gave us binary
answers to all D questions and we wanted
to estimate each each answer of the
belong to the underlying population opt
to an additive say gamma then al
infiniti distances essentially what we'd
be estimating the mean - so there's a
very natural notion of estimating the
mean but it seems like this one you have
to pay a lot more are any questions
about this slide
this chi-squared distance on the meat on
the vectors of beams yes correct so this
is estimating the mean of the
distribution in chi-squared distance
which corresponds to learning the
distribution itself in l1 otherwise it'd
be like why are we looking at this but
this is the one that seems to
characterize it yes yes sorry yeah that
should have been okay and we also have
corresponding where there's a one
dimensional problem which a vishesh in
Salil studied with John Jerry and Vic
Ron's as well we studied a high
dimensional version which roughly has
the same story in the sense we can pay a
mild dependence on the scale parameters
but again this is interesting compared
to the L infinity statement where you
really had to pay an exponential cost
okay I had some slides on distribution
learning versus reconstruction I'm kind
of running out of time so we can talk
about this more offline and why you know
reconstruction of attacks don't really
give good private learning lower bounds
also distribution learning versus linear
queries they're kind of different
questions in the sense that one we learn
all queries but for a simple class the
other one you learn some queries but for
a complex class again having talked
about the more offline
okay sure there's there's other problems
we could also consider such as things
like you know distributional function a
distributional functional estimation
where we're trying to privately estimate
some function of the underlying
distribution things which have been
studied a lot in the TCS community
include things like support size
distance to uniformity or entropy under
sort of the title that you might have
heard by Greg and Paul valiant
estimating the unseen and the
interesting thing in this case is that
these requires a
one interesting case that I want to
point out here is the fact that these
are known to be generally expensive
properties in the sense that if you
consider K being the domain side which
is large you have to pay something which
is almost linear in it but interestingly
we managed to show that you can get an
additive cost which is sort of a lower
order term in this sort of high large
domain setting so this is one place
where I consider the cost of privacy to
be somewhat negligible testing let me
just quickly state some results you can
so it's well another related question to
hypothesis testing ad before with
instead of trying to do either to say
one distribution or something far from
it there's what's known as simple
hypothesis testing in which we either
know it's some null hypothesis or some
particular alternative hypothesis that
is it's either one distribution or the
other and this is very well understood
problem in classical statistics in the
sense that there is what's known as you
know the log likelihood ratio test which
looks at this quantity here which I
won't parts for you but the Neyman
Pearson lemma one of the most classical
results here says that this log
likelihood ratio test is optimal that is
like no constant factors like this is
the best test that you can get it's
uniformly yeah it's the best test so in
case you like minimax bounds you can
actually show that the sample complexity
of this test for any two hypotheses q0
and q1 is going to be 1 over their
hollinger squared distance which is
another type of distance and so there's
a kind of very nice a nice story to tell
about this one test the issue is how to
privatise in the sense that privacy as I
mentioned before is related to the
sensitivity of the statistic and in
particular if you have one place where
the one PDF is very large and one is 0
or small or even zero then you can see
that this log likelihood ratio test
could be very very sensitive so the
question is how can you really privatize
it and if you're looking at a very
sensitive statistic and it turns out
that some test that's kind of like this
works now let me explain a bit
notation this sort of parentheses
notation means that we cap it to this
range in the sense that if it's bigger
than epsilon then we round the statistic
down to Epsilon and if it's smaller than
minus epsilon Prime we're going to round
it up to minus epsilon Prime once you do
that you can see that the sort of
statistic is bounded I've found it
sensitivity and then you can add Laplace
noise very simple statistic right
there's something I'm hiding here in the
fact that I said epsilon Prime and I
didn't state it and if I want to state
it this would probably - even just a
state like the result I think would be
at least another couple slides and it's
a very complicated measure of distance
now but the point is this epsilon prime
is actually quite a tough problem
quantity even to define so the main
thing I want to get across here is that
simple hypothesis testing while it was
very easily and well understood in the
and the non-private case it becomes much
more complicated here and this is a
result of Lamont cannon Audrey macmillan
Smith and John almond so this is not
quite neyman-pearson in the sense that
it's not as clean and neat as we would
like it's not optimal up to constants or
sorry it's optimal up to constants but
not optimal exactly so I feel like there
is there might be something better here
but it becomes just too complicated to
understand and I'll say that for certain
cases we can get uniformly most powerful
test which - I mentioned a bit before
but they can't be done in general do -
Brennan to seem this term used for
change point detection and let me skip
this other things there's other other
things they did not get a chance to
mention today are things like local
privacy there's been a lot of work but
of course I'm already over time so this
would have been a fool's errand to try
to cover all of these in detail and also
there's other related tasks which could
be generally considered as statistical
tasks including PCA clustering and you
know how to compute robust statistics
which are other things which I'll put
these slides online so you can peruse
all of these if you'd like anyway thank
you
then take the rest into the break
most of the slides in this show that
like you look at what you would normally
do one thing you do not privately and
then think of some newest addition based
on sensitivity either the I would say
more systematic way to approach the
problem under privacy by thinking for
example at you know I mean another way
to phrase my question is like is this
almost optimum maybe maybe that the
statistic that was optimum privately
lonely or optimal and you can think of
something else
I guess that's that's a good question I
say that you know in general if you want
to get the non-private optimal term you
kind of need it to be optimal in the non
private setting as well but the idea is
there may be multiple tasks as we sort
of saw for say identity or
goodness-of-fit testing and you know
choosing the right one they might be
amenable to privatizing in different
ways so it's kind of I don't I don't
think I personally have a theory of this
yet and I'm not sure if anyone does but
I think that's a very good question
trying to understand which families the
statistics may be more easily privatized
ville
yes quick question are you take it
otherwise maybe go on to the free
weekend I can alright well its thing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]